people across many cities in Pakistan
are rallying against the recent burning
of a Koran in Sweden the protests were
called by prime minister Shahbaz Sharif
some demonstrators are demanding that
the government cut off diplomatic tithes
with Sweden al-jazeera's Kamal Haider is
in Islamabad come on why don't you bring
us up to speed on the latest
there is a protest rally which is
underway here in Islamabad across
Pakistan they've been protest rallies
and all major cities by all major
political parties ordinary citizens also
taking part and of course there is
considerable anger because of the
incident of the burning of the Quran
outside of mosque in Stockholm now the
people here of course would want
stronger action they want to send a
message to the International Community
that such acts are intolerable they say
that nobody should be allowed to burn
anybody's religious books this is after
all the conservative Islamic country
there's also been some criticism as to
the delayed response from the government
it's almost a week since that incident
took place and so there is some anger
there but people across Pakistan across
the political divide are also of the
opinion and that the world must respect
other religions that such acts do little
to improve Interfaith Harmony and that
these are Intolerable Acts because they
also
appealed to the passions of the Islamic
world and the Muslims almost one and a
half billion Muslims around the world so
indeed a strong protest are but a
peaceful protest throughout the country
reporting from Islamabad thank you very
much